we want to fly again that Hitler's using
a possible Sanders and sister reunions
while at her annual Halloween event in
New York City the actress also dished on
whether she'd be interested in playing
Winnie again in the hocus pocus sequel
coming to Disney Plus I hope there are
Disney Plus it's a big success and I
hope to get to do it because she is of
course one of my favorite characters I
mean she's in the zeitgeist I have met
people who I met like grown-up people
like 40 year olds 50 year old to say oh
I remember that you hocus-pocus I was
brought up on it it's so mortified she
also says her witching on-screen sisters
Sarah Jessica Parker and Kathy Najimy
have just as much love for the Halloween
classic as she does she actually talked
about it whenever we see each other we
laugh we say Oh wouldn't it be great if
because all of us have pretty much the
same experience on it we all said we all
so how much fun the flying was while
speaking to et at hula ween Cathy shared
that if asked to appear she may have a
plot line in mind I think it'd be so
great to do a cameo find the three
witches I think that'd be really good
aside from her possible return to hocus
pocus Bette has been busy focusing on
her work with the New York restoration
project to help restore parks in the
city we have made some great we've made
Landscape Architects we've made urban
planners we have weave weave these are
jobs these are real jobs and and it's a
good thing one of the best things we did
was raise awareness for people in the
city that they were entitled to have
their green spaces clean so that they
could use them and enjoy them so it
seems like she may have her hands full
but fingers crossed we're gonna see what
happened
[Music]